meanwhile the Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg in the news a lot
well he just released this stunning new
body cam footage of those migrant
suspects in that brutal Beatdown on a
couple of cops in Time Square and now
seven of them have been indicted on
felony charges attorney and retired New
York City Police in inspector Paul
Morrow joins us live in the studio good
morning to you Paul morning you know
when you see the body cam video it was
one thing to see the exterior shot where
it was kind of fuzzy and you didn't
really see it this stuff is so graphic
those cops it it's amazing that Alvin
Bragg had that body cam video and still
let those guys walk originally yeah it
is amazing I mean you have to think
about it if you look at the body cam
footage you can see a number of the
perpetrators faces quite clearly right
so this idea that well we needed a lot
more time to ascertain who exactly the
perpetrators were Etc doesn't really
hold water that's number one number two
if the investigation evidence was so
fuzzy how did you charge them to begin
with right you didn't have probable
cause then to charge them but they did
charge them so that the idea that well
we don't have enough to hold them but we
did have enough to charge them that is
legally inconsistent Paul you know what
this is about uh that video that
surveillance video hit the news it was
on the cover of the New York Post
suddenly people are talking about it the
governor said I this was a bad idea to
release him his hands were tied he had
to appear to be doing something yeah
he's pedaling now and you know so he
comes out the seven indictments doesn't
really do much for the case okay you
already had them arrested it's good
don't get me wrong but here's the real
issue now he has an option because he's
got these indictments to advance the
case so what does that mean they have
return dates okay that's when you let
them out on Ro they have to come back
now to court because you got the
indictments you can move those dates up
right now those dates are in March
there's one in February the others are
in March you can now say to the judge
your honor these guys are dangerous
they're a flight risk we we're sitting
on seven indictments get them here fort
with and then the da can say and this
time we want bail let's see if he does
it yeah and I've heard a number they
think that as many as 14 people could be
involved in this Beatdown so let's see
if they are have any leads on that you
know we talk a lot about this being a
sanctuary City Paul and what people
sometimes think that means is you know
go to New York and they're going to take
care of you they're going to feed you
and stuff like that essentially the
Cornerstone of Sanctuary City status is
we will not cooperate with the feds
that's right and in this case the feds
are ice and border patol and stuff like
that and that is the problem that is so
I mean that's codified in law sometimes
it's an executive order in the case of
the state and Drew CUO put it in by
executive order that means Kathy hokel
could undo it by executive order I don't
see any movement towards that despite
all her lip her lip service right but
here in the city it's law through the
city council you'd have to go to the
city council and get a law to undo it
but under the law you can't cooperate
with ice very underst okay uh before you
go you know the streets of New York
right through that window back there are
more dangerous now than I have seen in a
very long time and I go way back here uh
a lot of it is with the migrants when it
comes to Street crime and we saw that
video a lady you know got dragged into a
parking meter because somebody was
trying to take her bag or her phone or
something like that and now apparently
the migrants have formed essentially
little mobs of organ crime and the
streets are not safe let's face facts
the majority of the migrants they're not
criminals we all know that nobody is
saying that on the other hand what seems
to be very clear here is that Maduro
emptied his prisons what we have here
now at the least is a Cadre of
Venezuelan prison gangs who Maduro has
visited upon us and why wouldn't he
learn from history 1980 Fidel Castro did
the same thing with the Mariel Boat Lift
it's in the movie Scarface if anybody's
ever seen it he took a page from his
well and the Cubans are very tight they
share int and all kinds of stuff he knew
what to do he emptied out his prison so
we have some bad ombres here as Donald
Trump likes to say and again it's not
everybody but it's getting to the point
that it's undeniable and here's the rub
here's the rub even if we say we're
going to deport them put them into ice
custody Maduro is not taking them back
they're here on a long way ticket no
kidding thank you for that history
lesson you're absolutely right Paul all
right happy to be here I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kill me and I'm anglehart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis